the room clock says 10 o'clock so
we'll go ahead and get started although
the two clocks different uh
I'm pretty sure that's true
all right I would like to open up the
work session on uh SB 71.
um appreciate everybody being here I
would like to start the meeting by just
um
logging my complaint that this really
shouldn't be with us as much as I'm
always happy to see the firefighters
um the content of this bill doesn't
isn't things that we usually cover or
are well versed and it's it's really
more of an insurance issue for the most
part or other than human services
potentially or labor I mean there's
pretty much everybody but us I don't
know how we landed with it but we'll do
our best for that because we're
certainly not subject
experts in this particular area so we'll
be looking at the two sections of this
bill the first part
having to do with the presumption of
cancer and expanding that in RSA 281 and
then the new section on a commission to
study the implementation of optional
annual cancer screenings uh did either
of you guys want to say anything before
I call anybody up to talk to us
no Mr Ella did you want to join us
thank you Mr chair Representatives
um Brian rill for the record uh
president of the professional
firefighters New Hampshire this was uh
Ryan could you just get a little bit
closer sure yeah thanks This was um
something that we had uh constructed to
try and
get rid of a little bit of ambiguity in
the current RSA
um and really just a cleanup of the
current bill uh at least the first
portion of this
um and
and we can talk a little bit about uh
depending on how you want to do things
here
um a little bit about why we think it's
ambiguous and a little bit confusing
under current law and what we're looking
to change
um yeah I think if we're let's start
with section one sure um and the idea of
presumption of cancer I I think that
language once again we don't hear this
language frequently in our committee so
like some clarity on that and how you
guys interpret it at the very least and
I know that you've brought Mr O'Connor
in as well to speak to that issue so
yeah if you wouldn't mind if if you can
join you that'd be great great
um so yes
good morning morning
Mr chairman Representatives just to give
a little background my name is Jared
O'Connor I'm with the firm of Shaheen
and Gordon and I've been practicing in
the area of workers compensation for
about 20 years it's really the sole
focus of my practice representing
Injured Workers I'm also on the
governor's commission to
establish a review presumption in for
PTSD in firefighters which I've now been
on for about three years
as well as the commission for the
compensation appeals Advisory board that
reviews the appointments to the
compensation appeals board which is the
body that hears appeals from Department
of Labor hearings so just a bit of
background on my experience so I thought
I'd make myself available at Brian's
request to answer any questions you have
about how presumptions work or how this
particular presumption operates in the
course of litigation at the labor
department yeah that second part if you
could speak to that I think would be
helpful to us how presumption works in
the appeal process sure so I guess I'd
be way of background
in the absence of a presumption which is
how every worker's comp case works it's
always the claimant's burden of proof to
establish that a condition is work
related that the injury arose out of a
risk that they're exposed to on the job
so it's as the claimant's attorney it's
our burden to bring forward that medical
evidence to show that in fact exposure
to such and such chemicals such and such
carcinogen is what well not carcinogen
but you know in the normal workers comp
case you have to show that the exposure
to risk on the job is what caused this
injury and then bring medical evidence
to prove that
what a presumption does what both the
PTSD presumption that has been passed
into law and any other kind of
presumption if it's a rebuttable
presumption as this is the idea is that
it flips the burden of proof so you walk
into a hearing or into any case with the
presumption that this injury is work
related so that's where the hearing
officer who's hearing the case is going
to begin from that premise that this is
a work-related injury unless it's proven
otherwise that's the difference and so
the burden of proof of who has to
establish this or who has to fight
against it is shifted from the claimant
which is normally us to prove that it's
related it shifts that burden to the
insurance carrier to prove that it's not
um which might sound more significant
than it is I mean at the end of the day
the the standard of proof in these
workers comp cases is a present a a
preponderance of evidence it's more
likely than not so when we're trying to
win a case from the claimant side we
have to bring in medical evidence to
show it's more likely that this injury
is work related than not
what a presumption does what this
presumption would do is just flip that
burden so that now it's on the insurance
carrier to prove that it's more likely
not work related which is a fairly
common and frankly easy thing to do from
uh their perspective you know I guess if
you're looking more broadly at how the
cancer presumption has worked in
practice and how this would work in its
expanded form
I guess I would say the expansion is not
that significant in that
you already have certain gatekeeping
functions in the statute as to who can
even qualify for the presumption in the
first place if you look at the statute
as it exists now
the
call or fire or volunteer firefighter
has to show that they were cancer-free
at the time of hire
um
the cancer as it exists uh under current
law has to be a kind that's recognized
by the a iarc the international body
that reviews cancer
and there has to be 10 years of service
the employer has to have met certain
guidelines with regard to following fire
standards and training curriculum for
Best Practices you have to meet all of
these before you even qualify for the
presumption in the first place
what this expansion would do is
basically expand it from The Limited
number of cancers that are presumed work
related now by the iarc to all cancers
so as long as those other conditions are
met
then if the firefighter has cancer then
you can make the claim that this is work
related
the carrier at that point has every
opportunity to deny the claim and then
review the medical records and determine
that well actually no you have a medical
history you're a remote smoker whatever
the other issues are and if they have
medical evidence to show that this is
not work related then the claim is over
at that point
so uh for clarification if this language
were to not go through yeah
um could a firefighter still bring a
claim for other cancers they just
wouldn't come with with presumption on
their side yeah that's exactly right
okay so we're not really expanding what
they can make a claim for just who Bears
the burden of proof that's exactly right
yeah anybody
claim for anything under current law
this the question is I mean even with
current cancers you may not enjoy the
benefit of the presumption because the
cancer you currently have may not fall
within the list of the iarc doesn't mean
you can't file a workers comp claim if
you have medical evidence to prove that
it's related all the presumption does
the presumption is just a procedural
mechanism it just shifts as you say it
shifts the burden of proof so it makes
it a little bit easier for Injured
Workers to qualify this area you can win
just on the medical evidence if the
medical evidence is strongly against you
then you're not even going to win with a
presumption you know you walk into that
hearing and the medical evidence
strongly points against this cancer
being work related the fact that their
presumption exists isn't particularly
going to help because the other side the
carrier the employer is going to be able
to show evidence all day long that this
is actually a genetic condition that has
nothing to do with work you're still
going to lose what the presumption does
is in the very narrow set of cases when
the medical evidence is genuinely
uncertain and it doesn't point in either
way either direction that strongly
in most workers comp cases Ty goes to
the employer
what the presumption does is that if
there is really an equipoise there in
terms of the medical evidence Ty goes to
the claim it and that kind of thing
doesn't happen very often because
generally speaking the medical evidence
is going to point more likely than not
in One Direction or the other okay
representative if I could too um just
touch on something that Jared mentioned
the while the benefit of presumption
isn't necessarily A a groundbreaking
notion right
we already have it uh many states
already have much more robust uh
presumption laws in place and while it
wouldn't change a lot of the procedures
uh for filing a workers comp claim at
the labor board what this what this does
primarily for us in this moment is it
shows a significant level of support
from the state to its firefighters to
say look we we have your back we want
you to get the care and treatment you
need we don't want you to suffer
financially because of that
and this is I mean we we've received no
opposition on on this portion of it
either from the senate or other
stakeholders that want to oppose this
legislation and I think a lot of that
has to do with the fact that
um there's significant medical evidence
now that's showing us every day that we
go to work we're donning personal
protective equipment uh that actually is
littered with pfas chemicals
um and to do that to protect our
communities is uh we believe that the
presumption is is kind of a
um a small well a large for us a large
flow of support from the state side to
say look we want you to have this
benefit of presumption but if your
cancer is clearly not work related it
won't be covered as it currently is not
covered
um so obviously this is workman's comp
this isn't health insurance right I mean
they're two different things
um would this have uh potentially in
inverse impact on workman's comp rates
If This Were to pass do you see that
having any impact whatsoever the the
impact that it could have would be
a marginal increase in the amount of
medical costs that the workers comp
insurance carrier is going to bear and
then therefore you know rates to the
employer but so it's a question of
um it's a question of how how many cases
end up being approved uh and then the
medical costs associated with that and I
guess what I would say is just to sort
of elaborate a little more on what Brian
was saying
having been involved now on the PTSD
commission and the change in the law
that we had there uh early last year
I do I want to speak to that for a
minute because I think it helps the
analogy is basically equivalent so
PTSD in firefighters or in any employee
had already been covered under workers
comp if you have a mental stress claim
in workers comp if you can prove that
it's work related then it can be covered
under comp and what the commission was
put together to study was whether there
should be a presumption in this subset
this subclass of employees that this
condition is work related and the reason
that it was approved and put into law is
the theory behind a presumption at least
for PTSD is that unlike other kinds of
workers
firefighters First Responders you know
EMT police when they take a job they are
very likely to develop PTSD at some
point in their career it's sort of it
comes with the territory in a way that
for example you know if you're a teacher
or a 7-Eleven clerk you're not likely to
have PTSD in the course of your job now
you might get held up as a 7-Eleven
Clerk and then develop PTSD because of
that one incident and so if that happens
you have a perfectly valid workers comp
claim to say that you have now anxiety
and stress because of what happened on
the job but it's rare it's unusual and
it's not it's not why you took the job
it doesn't come with the territory with
firefighters police EMT Corrections
Officers
that kind of mental stress and PTSD it
comes with the territory you're signing
up for that when you take the job like
you know it's likely to happen and
that's why the presumption was put in
place
I would submit that the same kind of
thing is happening with regard to cancer
and firefighters you know the evidence
is beginning to show and the iarc is
developing a rubric to establish that
the status of being a firefighter is an
occupational risk for cancer you know
it's much more likely that you're going
to develop cancer As A Firefighter than
you are in any other maybe not any other
but in most other fields of occupation
and so that's the theory behind why a
presumption makes sense
um and in terms of the Practical effect
which is essentially what you're asking
the PTSD presumption now having been in
place for two years what I've seen at
least in my own practice so this is
anecdotal but it hasn't prevented
insurance carriers from denying claims I
still have to mitigate these cases from
time to time it's just you know the easy
cases are approved
the easy cases where it's clearly not
work related are denied and frankly
don't get litigated it's again these
marginal cases when the evidence could
kind of cut either way in the case of a
PTSD claimant you've got someone who
maybe has pre-existing
experience in combat or childhood trauma
or something like that where there's
evidence that suggests well you know
they have PTSD but is it work related or
isn't it and so you hash that out at the
labor department
this what the cancer presumption does is
essentially the same thing you know if
there's evidence that cuts both ways you
go to the labor department you have a
hearing both sides present their
evidence and you see what the result is
the effect of the presumption doesn't
prevent either side from going through
that due process at the labor department
What It ultimately does is again if the
evidence is a close call on either side
then it can tilt in favor of the injured
worker but
uh because that is such a small set of
cases I think that the the Practical
effect the financial impact on
municipalities is not likely to be
significantly greater over the long haul
it just makes
it makes the experience of having cancer
As A Firefighter dealing with that and
getting the treatment that you need a
little bit easier
to put it uh in a little one second
friend sorry did anybody you guys have
any you have any questions Chris
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question
um
it's been said before that we don't not
this normally handle something like this
and this so but that's okay because I'm
ignorant on all things even the ones we
do handle
uh the carrier so one of your gentlemen
said the carrier can deny the claim
who's the carrier
um for most for most firefighters in the
state it's primex the city of Nashua and
the City of Manchester are both
self-insured but for most other
municipalities in the state primex tends
to be the carrier that I see involved in
these cases
and when uh workman's comp case goes
there
are they going before New Hampshire
workman's comp or are they going before
the carrier
so the way this works is that when a
claim is filed for a workers comp injury
it's presented to that that piece of
paper that files the claim is presented
to the labor department and to the
employer's insurance carrier so that
piece of paper that says I have a
workers comp claim or I'm claiming one
goes to the labor department in primex
primex then has 21 days to either accept
the claim or deny it
if denied then the claimant has a year
and a half to challenge it by requesting
a hearing at the labor department so the
initial brief investigation is done by
the insurance carrier but the hearing to
actually present evidence present expert
reports get testimony if necessary that
goes to the labor department so a
hearing is held
here in Concord at the labor department
with appeal rights thereafter
I've only got 12. that's less than usual
[Laughter]
so if the if the carrier
doesn't deny the claim does it go to
labor department workman's comp if the
carrier accepts the claim then there's
no need to go to the labor department
right they just accept it and can pay
although I should say having accepted
the claim doesn't mean that they're
irrevocably bound to pay forever they're
always free at some point in the future
to say all right well we now question
whether this remains related
um and they they have ongoing rights to
challenge ongoing treatment if necessary
so on on section two the notwithstanding
path yeah
[Music]
um
I guess what is it notwithstanding
sections
now withstanding section 216 and 27.
yeah right at the beginning yep yep so
if this became law
if a firefighter claims
a cancerous
situation is caused by his job
whether it's on
the
list now right
it it would be
assumed that the cancer was job related
and it seems like
that makes the carrier or or workman's
comp hearing
prove the negative
and I don't know how you prove the
negative so okay that's essentially
right that that's the point of a
presumption is that it it there's a
prima facial presumption Prima fascia
just means that in the first instance
we're going to assume this is work
related unless you can prove it's not
and so it does shift the burden of
production of producing evidence to
Prime X to then show that this cancer is
not work related the way they do that
and the way they do that in the PTSD
cases I'm involved with for example is
they have the right once a workers comp
claim is filed to get the claimant's
medical records historical records
having anything to do with the claimed
injury so they have a right to gather
those records to have those records
reviewed by their own expert and that
expert can then say
because of whether other environmental
exposures because of your personal
history because of genetic history that
I can say as primex's expert this is not
in fact due to your exposure as
firefighter it's due to
obesity smoking whatever and so they
then present that to the labor
department the labor department has the
authority to review those expert reports
and say this is more credible the denial
is upheld
or not depending on how the litigation
goes
representative I'm not going to add to
that
um just recently we had a case in Dover
of testicular cancer which is a cancer
that's currently covered under the iarc
list
that claim was denied and the subsequent
review of IT upheld the denial based on
other factors so they were able to the
Not only was the workers comp carrier
able to deny the claim even though
on its on its face it met every one of
the benchmarks upon further review the
upheld the denial and the member did not
get the Pres the presumptive or the
workers comp coverage so
um as Jared mentioned earlier it is a
fairly easy Benchmark to reach in order
to continue to deny these claims whether
or not the presumption's in place
right
you can continue if you had something
else sure thank you I just wanted to
touch on
um kind of expand upon the
the reason why the expansion makes sense
to us uh the the current language refers
to uh that it must be a cancer involved
must be a type which may be caused by
exposure to heat radiation or a known
carcinogen as defined by the
international Agency for research on
cancer now when you go to look for that
list of cancers that must be caused by
exposure to heat radiation or known
carcinogen and this was a link that I
sent to all to all the committee members
the iarc has a a monograph a list it's I
believe 14 pages long of all types of
cancers
there is nothing that specifically
States uh
exposure to heat radiation or known
carcinogen and in fact the language at
the top of the form refers to
carcinogens that are likely to occur in
humans and that's the entire list
um
so in 2018 when this legislation was
passed that was put in there
to try and click make some
clarifications as to what was covered
and what was not
um to my knowledge the intention was to
cover the cancers on that list
and in turn if you take it if you
dissect it further you can you
some have pulled out about seven cancers
that are actually covered from the iarc
but then if you look at uh
previous reports from the iarc from 2010
there's at least an additional eight
that should be covered by this same
organization and they're not they're not
being covered right now or at least
under our presumptive legislation so who
interprets that so that well that would
be a labor board decision but
um I know that the researcher for the
committee sent out an email that said
there were these seven cancers were
covered but you can you can search I
mean they there's articles from the IRC
um that I can even I'll read it to you
uh 2010 report from the iirc considers
there to be sufficient evidence for
firefighter exposures causing the
following types of cancers that are not
listed in those seven and it lists an
additional eight cancers
um
and
further to that the CDC uh cites an
additional nine cancers that are on
neither one of those lists that
firefighters are at increased risk for
so
um it's the the list is not exhaustive
of what we're what we have increased
exposure to and that's what we're trying
to to figure out here it's not you know
we're not trying to bamboozle the system
and say we should be covered for
everything that's why there are all
these other as Jared mentions
requirements to get through the gate in
the first place and then there's this
review process that really determines
whether or not
we are eligible to receive receive the
coverage right
okay
any other questions guys
is anybody from the labor board here
this morning
they don't seem to be too worried about
it now as I mentioned um I mean this
went through the Senate uh Edna five to
zero and it passed the Senate uh in
quick Fashion on a Voice vote
unanimously
um there was no opposition in the Senate
I I think and I'm just speculating here
but I think realistically
um just that case that I mentioned about
the testicular cancer really the
requirements to refute a presumptive
claim
um are not that difficult at the moment
um so I think that maybe why there's not
a ton of pushback on this great
is there anybody else in the room that's
kind of a subject matter expert that can
add something that hasn't been stated
already
thank you gentlemen we may call you back
in a bit
hi my name is Christian Cyril I'm the
chief property and casually actuary at
the New Hampshire insurance department
don't know if it's going to add anything
but it's just gonna
kind of support what Jared said
regarding rates so there was the
question about how it might affect
premiums
um
so two points to that as Jared mentioned
um if it if it does have an effect it
would certainly
um affect premiums on the increase
because you are
the the end result would likely be more
claims and then over time those claims
would affect rates however
again it is quite likely that the number
of additional claims would be quite
minimal
in the grand scheme of workers comp
claims for firefighters and don't forget
firefighters will only make up one part
of the pool of
of folks that are insured through primex
so primex generally handles
municipalities and so
it would be I would expect it to be
quite minimal the um the other thing to
mention is primex is not regulated by
our department
um primex is the pool that handles
municipalities and so um
that oversight goes through the
Secretary of State's office and labor
department but just from an Actuarial
perspective would probably be quite
minimal
um the other thing that I'd like to ask
a question about or just have you keep
in mind the other portion of the bill
that talks about
um the screening
that would be
Jared might know this as well but from
my perspective in looking at workers
comp that would be unusual in a workers
comp system and so there might be
questions
for primex or carriers as to
how that cost would be
would be shared and how that cost would
be studied and how that might affect uh
premium but that might be a question for
it would be mission for the commission
probably if we format yeah it doesn't
exist yet um and just for clarification
for everybody uh workman's comp claim in
this scenario isn't more expensive than
another kind of workman's comp claim
necessarily or is it
you mean through primex because yeah so
if somebody makes a Cancer claim it's
the same as another kind of working on
claim together
um what do they call it like like work
related uh illness diagnosis like like
carpal tunnel or something like that you
know where it's it it progresses over
time and there isn't one particular
you know
you know accident or incident and and
but that happens in all sorts of
different occupations okay great thank
you for that clarification
any questions guys yes representative
true
thank you Mr chair
I know you I know you said that in your
opinion the
the workman's comp rates
may go up
or probably would but it would be very
small amount
yeah it's impossible to tell
um and again this takes many many years
or because it's not as if it is very
unlikely that primex would change their
rates because of this change in the law
it is they would wait to see how the law
affects claims
um because there are
kind of opposing
you know forces here
you know
there is the POS like if there's that
presumption you know then there might be
fewer arguments there might be you know
fewer fewer legal battles that go on
because there are more claims that they
know they're going to pay you know
um
and so they may they may save costs on
defense or or legal expenses and that
would be might get converted over to
Indemnity or medical payments there's
the other piece where if you know if the
commission over time ends up approving
and recommending and then we go into
um you know this you know the cancer
screening
that could have the effect of reducing
medical costs over time and so you just
you know they're so yes there might be
more claims but they might be less
expensive it's very difficult to tell
how all those different variables will
will kind of work off each other
yep yeah but intuitively yes it would be
more expensive
but details will will come with time
so on
so for primex
you don't know how they're going to
react or what they're going to say as a
company whatever but
they wouldn't say oh my god look they
just passed this law and now we have to
jack up the rates to cover
future costs
um
they would be more apt to say
over the course of 20 years
more cancers were covered under
workman's comp and therefore we're going
to raise the rates
right if I was primex's actuary I I
would recommend
wait and see primex you know as as a
pool
right I mean
I I don't know how that pool is
structured
I mean it isn't a for-profit
organization right so
they you know they have
a board
you know they answer to ultimately the
Secretary of State's office
they need to justify their actions and
their decisions and their rates to
someone
um
my guess is that would wait and see they
would wait and see you know thank you
for that piece of information it's I
didn't realize that primex wasn't a
for-profit organization that's a helpful
piece of information
once again not our subject matter most
of the time so we're learning a bunch of
stuff as we go
yeah go ahead so that that brings up 13
more questions I'll keep it to one
so so who is primex so primex is is
is the all the municipalities in New
Hampshire
pooling
their risk is that what primex is right
and
Jared may know something about this as
well so feel free to join him too if
it's helpful
it's it's very um very laid back
I don't know to what extent primex is
the hired
um adjuster and and uh kind of the
logistics service provider for the pool
or whether primex is itself the pool
that's a great question
what are you referring to is like
sometimes if you wouldn't mind speaking
like just because it's also recorded
sure we can we can hear you but they can
um
what he's referring to is that in some
instances like for example like the city
of Manchester in the city of Nashville
are both self-insured for workers comp
meaning they pay all of the costs of the
workers comp claims that come before
them but they don't themselves well
Nashua kind of does but Manchester
doesn't administer the claims they hire
what's called a third party
administrator to administer the claims
and file the paperwork and keep track of
medical bill denisles and just handle
the day-to-day operations of the workers
comp activity but the checks that are
actually written for people's weekly
Indemnity or disability benefits and all
the medical benefits come from the city
so that's Manchester and Nashua but for
all other municipalities it's primex and
again I don't know the answer whether
primex is just a third party
administrator that I I don't think they
are I think they are the insurer and I
think municipalities just pay the
pay the insurance premiums to primex
thank you
you're good representative
okay
great
thank you gentlemen
um do you guys want to hear anything
else on the first section are you
comfortable moving to the second section
at least information gathering West okay
great so Mr rill if you want to address
again
walk us through the study commission
which there was one a few years ago
right that's how we got the first
presumptive language but this one's
going to be looking at something a
little bit more Broad
so yes I apparently so uh I wasn't I
wasn't around for that but um
so the intent and it's it's no ass
actually if you can hang on for just a
second Steve can you come up for a
second then
sure for the record Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District
which encompasses Dairy what was that
what was the primary focus of that study
commission so that study commission
occurred uh prior to me being a
legislator I was involved in the
corrective they did a
um language cleanup like we like to call
it
my first term as a they missed something
when they filed that that first bit of
presumptive language
um
the term before my father was actually a
co-sponsor of that so they had a
as this body tends to do when we come up
with a new concept we love to we have
what do we have 300 commissions and
committees that exist right so they
looked at this as gen in generalities in
in kind of holistically as my
understanding and then brought forward
the legislation that we have which
currently
definitely has holes and problems in it
right so
um and that's why we're this language is
now before you guys again to as I will
call it a second revision to fix a
couple of other things that came as a
result of the 20
I think it was 20 yeah 18 or 2016.
commission that happened but I didn't
sit on it but that's that's my
understanding haven't been involved in
the first language cleanup Bill okay
okay so just it might be beneficial to
take a look at that and see if there's
any useful information in it since it's
already been done
um not saying that that affects whether
or not we do this one I'm just saying
it's out there so we can we have access
to it one of the things that's happening
right now
um
is twofold one the focus within the fire
service on cancer has really just
expanded dramatically as the revelations
of things have come forward
that's that's part of it the other thing
that's happened and
it's in 2023
is for 200 years firemen have been
fighting fire and fighting cancer but
now women are entering this profession
in numbers never seen before
so the kind of the Baseline that we have
of the of the concept of a common cancer
amongst men is is there we're
establishing those those baselines based
on historical data what we have for
women in this profession is nothing
nothing
so when you when you come up with a list
of cancers under under presumption to
say okay these are the common things you
know we talk about testicular cancer
what we don't have in these presumptive
lists is things that are specific to
women
and that's why the idea of going that's
why this bill's idea of saying look
let's not be solely restricted to a
small list of things in an emerging
field of study
that has really only ever been studied
in men
and that's why this
this particular legislation that passed
the Senate
can address the the continuing changes
that are ongoing and not having to
continuously revisit every every two
years this type of legislation to add
another cancer or another variant or
another
circumstance you see what I'm saying
because we get we get into the weeds I
mean you've we all see the commercials
on TV you know types type 17 non-hodgkin
whatever and you look at that and go
what the hell is that thing well what if
you're type 16 or 14 or whatever and as
a 27 year firefighter I can tell you
that there's two words that scare the
hell out of us one is layoff and two is
cancer
so having to go through a battle and go
through this process of of having a some
sort of a weird list that has to
constantly be changed and amended
responsively instead of proactively
is just another example of how
government is just either too slow or
or just too behind things and I think
this takes care of that and you know
obviously as you heard from attorney
O'Connor you know this is not
in in people's minds when they Define
presumption or they Define a process in
their own head as we've learned that's
really just not how it is so I I think
that this
is a truly important thing for the for
that profession for the reasons I listed
and I think it would just be another
situation where the legislature can just
put an end to something
thanks Mr back to you sure
um so much like part one of this uh in
the expansion this the study commission
portion of this while it's it's
Progressive in nature it's certainly not
groundbreaking other states uh other
states are doing these screenings now
and I wanna what I want to be clear
about is this is not a a commission to
study whether or not screenings are
appropriate or whether or not
firefighters should be getting screened
for cancer we we know that uh should be
beneficial for all of us right
um what this Commission
uh would be tasked hopefully with doing
would be determining how to implement a
process and a program that would include
uh
things like
what's the cost going to be to implement
this program who's going to pay for it
where's the is there going to be a cost
sharing is the state interested in that
cost sharing uh how much will the
employee have to pay what type of
screenings are necessary
what other states are doing this now are
the programs successful
administratively how would a program
like this be be put together
um these are all things that we want to
take a look at
New Jersey is already doing cancer
screenings for firefighters
um
Massachusetts is already doing cancer
screenings for firefighters we actually
have local some local municipalities in
the state now that are doing some form
or another of cancer screenings for
firefighters in fact
um there's and I won't break the news
early but there's a community in our
state that has worked with insurance
providers and Dartmouth Hitchcock and is
looking to implement cancer screenings
for firefighters this is not new stuff
it is Progressive in nature but it's not
like I said oh my God I can't believe
that you know we're going to be
establishing a committee to look at
doing cancer screenings for firefighters
it's already being done so you know
rather than come in here and and say
can we have
10 million dollars or 100 million
dollars or however much money to say we
want to implement skin cancer screenings
we want to do chest x-rays we want to do
CAT scans we want to do whatever other
cancer screening is available and here's
the cost to it and being laughed out of
the room we'd rather do this
purposefully
and and sit down and work with all of
you and say let's look at how a program
like this could be implemented and then
bring it back to the legislature at a
later date and say can we implement it
so that's the purpose for part two and
it's no accident that these were placed
together as was mentioned earlier by the
gentleman from the insurance agency
um
there could potentially be however small
a slight increase in workers
compensation premiums over time
you've heard everybody testify here that
if that happens it's going to be minimal
but it could happen nonetheless now this
study commission portion is attached to
it because we believe that if there are
cancer screenings in place
early detection and early treatment are
going to drive costs of treatment down
and so claims are going to be less in
the long run and that's how this how
these programs have been so successful
um throughout other states is that
they've been able to get insurance uh
companies riskable providers medical
providers and municipalities on board
with implementing something like this
thank you questions
yeah Steve if you wouldn't mind letting
Mr O'Connor back up that'd be great
just I just wanted to sorry I just
wanted to follow up on that last thing
that Brian was saying which is that what
he just mentioned is exactly how it has
worked with the PTSD presumption which
is that the law was changed to put the
PTSD presumption into place and the
commission remains active in meeting on
a monthly basis to review its effect
both on rates and on the community at
large and how it's working in practice
and so
just thought that was worth noting is
that that's that's how that structure
has worked with the with regard to the
presumption for PTSD and First
Responders great thank you so much
thanks
Penny further questions from the
committee
thank you Mr well appreciate it
thoughts yeah
representative true
thank you Mr chair so there's a
commission doing this now no there was a
commission back in either 2016-2018 that
brought that original presumptive
language that we're looking at into law
that was their recommendation so
um we're not going to vote on anything
today we'll vote tomorrow morning when
we have everybody here Peter and Jason
should be with us so
um
but looking at the amendment that
representative true brought forward
how are you feeling about that Amendment
it's not ready for prime time okay I
don't think I'd have one ready for
tomorrow
I'd probably wait and see how the
committee felt if the committee wanted
to go try to come up with an amendment
that we all agreed with
fine but but he is
here's what I was attempting to do with
the with my Amendment and and granted
it's it's not right
I wanted to delete section one
change the the Sunset date to November
1st 2024. so that they actually have
some time to do it so because that was
mentioned in in our first in our hearing
that 2023 was even though it was worded
wrong wasn't enough time to do the to do
what work had to be done
um
another change I made was to change the
attorney appointed by the New Hampshire
Association of Justice
a uh my notes said Marissa Chase
representing the trial lawyers of New
Hampshire asked if they be
replaced that so I put that in
um however
and I gave everyone a copy of uh house
bills 1269 from from last year
the way this commission is set up
the legislature is not the majority and
according to that law the legislature
legislatures must be the majority of the
commission
so
right now and this is not not a change
this is something I found after I got
the uh
the my Amendment drafted
the most members the commission can have
is 15.
and eight of those must be from the
legislature
I think the the general feeling was
because
we have a boss
and we should be the ones
driving that that car right
so that that's another change that will
so we'd have to we'd have to pull one
other representative or one other member
of the
outside of the legislature off and
replace it with a legislative member yes
so and then the question would be who do
you cut out right
um that's why I didn't bother doing
another one because who am I to say I'll
leave that up to the uh
to the the sponsor or the committee
assignments
okay
read any thoughts
all right
um
okay why don't we reach this recess this
until tomorrow morning we have another
meeting in this room at nine uh to look
at this again and I'll make sure that
the other guys are going to be here for
that and uh in the meantime I'll do a
little bit more digging on the
makeup of the commission and what that
looks like
um
and we'll see if we can pull something
together for tomorrow because we're
supposed to exec it tomorrow afternoon
oh yeah it's scheduled I mean I'm sure
that Carol could recess it if she wants
to but we're scheduled for tomorrow
because we're not going to wrap
everything up tomorrow right no we have
one more on the 23rd of May I think so
there is one more work day
um
but
sure any other thoughts nope all right
I'll go I'll go ahead and research
recess the work session on the SB 71
done until tomorrow morning at 9am